або хто я по тушонку приїхала скр його
добив його церкви або дві дати парад
новим роком батьки у свою людину
сні ви командир танку засуну богдан по
тушонку пішов на фронт в 1 не минуло
руку і до сина повернувся пологи вдома
нам а голоси тут уват і
та й їх не богдан через російську
пресу не знала seven ж 11 місяців у
підлозі не упр і мінську думу новини
передача вич обмін по місяцю нами
мавпами нам три рази їх шу результату
сяду мінська то спочатку на porsche їм
мінську поголив еша обміню до 6 бар і
дня а потім до 9 травня потім до виборів
і на хіба нам abyssal і щоб дали
нову руку
головні органи як is as any травня пік
лове себе огненном по місяцю нами
спеціально створ він і центр свавілля
свою гуманітарну місію за допомогою
Місяцю нам закону та червоний хрест
спочатку конфлікту на донбасі сюди
вивернулася а маже шутери сторін in all
емісії не зайшли в даєте відрив від і
доступ до планет і мене кінчати і ми
адже бачила 589
пов'язаних українцями всіх місць і
не треба конфлікт урізати її 2015 нам
далося або twitter та 4 панелях вже катували
у pid контроль розуму днр дунайський
повністю та нитками астані обмін повний
іншому виду все на прокинь сили ступа так
і за раз процесу тіло займався поважаючи
голова волонтерської організації
офіцерський корпус володимир ван
переговорну групу призначено перед кутом
пупери блискавку при значенні тих хто
нове життя до одіозних політичних
груп в Україні
зиг та ми донецька сторона на божа cidade
і застиг перемелює сідати за стіл
переговорів та щодо кальцій паритет
зберігає тягнеться на будинок кургану про
скоро обмін плані нами може діалог
мішки і вам і москвою на ремені
президент у нацист одягається і руди на
богдану по тушонку як наша йому
борошно і чекаємо на новий лік дядька рік
якушина новий рік не повернуться його
дружина вікторія розум меншим родичами
готова вийти на акцію протесту проти с
діяльності влади